[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
welcome back to joke world my guest
today is comedian john jacobs john has
been on the mtv and netflix show are you
the one and also performed stand-up
comedy all across the country working
with the likes of big j ogresson doug
stanhope anthony juesselnik and more i
wonder if anybody's gonna be mad at this
content so right when you think 911
can't get any worse
it creates dj khaled and finished on her
face leticia said you were shooting
fireworks and like threw them off your
balcony and they were like exploding
everywhere and it was really dangerous
leticia called me gay if you cut the
controversial stuff out of this episode
it'll be about three minutes long smoke
fentanyl you can actually do that try it
i always think about doing porn i'm
always like if any of you guys want to
have sex with john jacobs here's a fun
story circling back to 9 11.
i said 9 11. i said [ __ ] i'm done
this podcast is the equivalent of a dj
khaled album starts now and it's [ __ ]
over the magic's gone but yeah i love
juice world too
sometime sometime
i'm gonna do a little introduction for
you yeah please no no in my like after
this oh we can just start doing this
right now we're in it now yeah like we
don't need any warm whiskey ginger style
just like sure the solo intro then right
back in yeah no that's good but yeah
we're talking about uh how we came up
with this i'm just a big juice world fan
yeah in general and i went through a lot
of names trying to come up with this
channel i had like comedy cone was okay
it was like a microphone like a ice
cream cone really bad uh like joke
um joe gravy i think was one shows like
a ladle a bunch of gravy coming sounds
disgusting these are all so bad yeah
comedy comes that's like a little kid
thing yeah uh [ __ ] what where were
some other ones um comedy house like
something very eric like just like a mic
not bad sure and then i don't know how i
ended up here but as soon as i i thought
of joke world like juice world spelling
i was like so embarrassed by the other
suggestions yeah kind of like how i am
right now well it's good uh do you know
why juice world took the o out i don't
know why
probably just because he's like a cool
black guy cool yeah it's a cool thing to
do yeah world i don't know yeah i don't
know either but now it's kind of like uh
accidentally
in a in a
very removed way no that's great i can't
believe somebody made this for you yeah
shout out smug rugs
oh smug rose smug rugs yeah very cool
yeah no nobody's ever made me anything
isn't that hilarious the 15 years of
comedy now somebody made me like a
digital collage once which was pretty
cool that's good yeah somebody just
asked like what are your favorite things
and uh i was like akuma from street
fighter
lobster
i'm from dc it was great they like put
all this [ __ ] in from the white house
and like
washington wizards logos so it was
pretty cool yeah so that's that's what
you want after 15 years i know it had
nothing to do with stand up it was
because they were a fan of my mtv show
you had an mtv show i did i know you
don't even know wow i had a show on
netflix whoa it was a top 10 show
whoa i know it was i did a show called
are you the one okay and uh that came
out on mtv in like 2014
but for some reason they put it on
netflix in 2020 and it was a top 10 show
and they didn't even tell us that they
were putting it up oh yeah some random
person on instagram was like i'm so
pumped for your netflix sean i was like
what and then they showed the schedule
and it said it was coming out what was
the show about because that sounds super
familiar it was reality dating were you
in hawaii hosting the show or were you a
date i was a i was a contestant
assistant yeah that has a lot to do with
stand up no it was yeah it was just
something to do but uh yeah you know i
was uh 24
and uh that's your age yeah oh for
everybody keeping track this is the
first one in his home yeah he said it
was going to be in the lobby of his
apartment complex because lobbyists
do look like
podcasts
exactly that's how they design them yeah
they're like we need this to be used as
a lobby then also if one of our tenants
has a youtube channel they can also use
this as a podcast studio no yeah you
guys can't see but this is a nice
apartment it's got like purple neon
lights around the borders
this feels like one of those rooms where
uh they shoot porn in south beach
you know it is actually this is where
the bang bus is driving to
if you stay before they arrive
eventually i'm just like i'm trying to
work i'm trying to edit videos in here
and stuff yeah people are just banging
no you look like a dj
yeah you have the hair you have a long
sleeve shirt some sort of black pants
respect yeah yeah you look like you're
like carrying zed's equipment to the
casino or whatever i think you look like
the guy from workaholics i do i got my
timetable yeah probably a lot yeah he's
got the curly hair of the straight hair
yeah if you really curled it up though
yeah i think yeah we got a similar look
i look like all of the workaholics
combined that's good yeah yeah you got
the height too of uh
yeah you got
jays i just played basketball perry
harvey senior park in tampa oh hang out
so how often do you hoop because all the
time yeah and it's mostly by myself
but uh there's a lot of homeless people
at the park i play with homeless people
and tweakers and [ __ ] really oh yeah you
just do you dominate oh yeah [ __ ] it's
great i've only gotten beat by a
homeless guy one time only one dude it
was like the best moment of his life i
swear to god he broke down crying he
breaks down crying
and he goes he's like tell my son i love
him i don't know who the [ __ ] his kid is
he goes tell my son i love him they're
gonna kill me they're trying to kill me
but he was so happy to win oh yeah i
don't know what the [ __ ] he was telling
him but but next time i saw him i beat
his ass yeah i didn't let that stand
[ __ ] that guy no i play a lot of
homeless people and they they're usually
very aggressive
for the first few minutes right but they
get gassed out so dude i bet they're
endurance no stamina oh yeah it's
hilarious they have a better offseason
plan yeah they need a they need to
figure it out but um one time i was
playing with a guy and um in the middle
of playing with him he
fell asleep holding the ball
and then he like woke up out of it and
just walked away while holding the
basketball and trying to like chase him
like whoa dude
what are you doing and they just
completely forgot what was going on damn
but yeah that's fine you get your ball
back i didn't get my ball back did you
call him for for that travel
well yeah he he didn't he completely
forgot what was happening at all he
stopped playing with playing basketball
yeah he forgot he was playing basketball
everything oh yeah it's awful i feel
like a hobo alarm clock a lot of times
because homeless people just sleep on
the court and then i show up and it's
like 1pm yeah and i start playing and
they're pissed they're like oh what the
[ __ ] and i'm like dude you're sleeping
on a basketball court right what did you
expect you got it yeah so one time a guy
was sleeping under the hoop like right
under the neck and it's like she's
asking for it yeah you're literally
begging me
but yeah so i play with tweakers and
[ __ ] and we have a good time yeah it
feels like i feel like i'm giving back i
was gonna say instead of giving money i
feel like that would be a way
i'm working them out exercise
human connection yeah um i don't do that
much charity but i do feel like this is
a good more charity than most people i
think the most charitable thing i did
was i let my neighbor's kid have my
wi-fi password okay and he used it for
like three years that's so good oh yeah
i'm like i'm going to heaven for sure
although i'm sure that kid probably
could have or his family could have
afforded their own wi-fi i don't know if
they should have
their own wi-fi but they didn't they
just let the it was hilarious the mom
was like hey can my son use your wi-fi
and he came over and like it was like
yeah what's the password and i'm like
well i guess it's your wi-fi now forever
like what the [ __ ] it's not like you can
take that back if you change the
password does it kick them out probably
it would have but i didn't do that yeah
one time i tried to make a deal with uh
the woman who lived under me to share
wi-fi i moved in and she gave me her
password and then she changed it after
like a month
and you know apparently it was because i
was having too much loud sex
she told me that she killed her wi-fi
she changed the wi-fi she kicked me dude
congrats on the loud sex dude i saw her
and i'm like hey what's up leticia her
real name and she was a white woman
which made no sense a white woman named
leticia can't have that she was awful
of course she's going to see this and
murder me
about the life that she that she lived
no she moved because i [ __ ] too loud
she swear to god she moved [ __ ] and uh
so i see her after like a month and a
half i live in there i go hey what's up
she goes ever since you moved in i've
been living in hell
you know what she goes i can't sleep
because you and your girlfriend are
having loud sex every night i'm doing
bad at my job because i'm tired every
day she's like you've you've ruined my
life she said you ruined my life and i
wanted to be like you know you want to
come upstairs and see what all the
hype's about but i didn't say that i was
like i'm sorry
and then even where like it can
besides the loud sex one time i threw
fireworks off my balcony that were
shooting okay and they were shooting
yeah they were loud roman candles okay
and they were too big and we got worried
because they were like shooting way too
hard right and we were like oh [ __ ] and
it was shooting onto bayshore and all
these cars were honking and stopping
yeah so we chucked them off my balcony
and they started shooting like at
leticia's balcony and she was sitting
outside
and uh
well so when i moved in
she i was moving in with a hello kitty
microwave and her and her friend were on
her porch there's a lot going on oh
there's so much here and she goes uh her
friend goes ask him and she goes i don't
want to say it and i go what's up and
she goes uh her friend goes well she
just wanted to know if you're gay
and i go no okay because they go well we
saw the microwave right i go yeah yeah
yeah so you know so later when she's
like
too much exactly like what did you get
right and then so i get in trouble for
the fireworks
yeah the leasing agent they put a note
on my door and they go you got to come
to the office right now and i go [ __ ]
and i come in and they go uh
leticia said you were shooting fireworks
and like threw them off your balcony and
they were like exploding everywhere and
it was really dangerous and i go uh i go
leticia called me gay
and they just are like
okay yeah you're fine we're not gonna
we're not gonna bother you and then
leticia moved it's not funny because
[Music]
maybe if you actually were gay you could
take some like like their the the
apartment building is like oh she just
called you gay yeah but you're not but
you're still gonna be like it's not okay
yeah you shouldn't ever call somebody
well i guess she just asked if i was
good
but still not okay don't ask don't tell
yeah that's what the military says don't
ask don't tell me no it's not i agree
now you have to tell now military is
like you have to be gay to join well now
the gay people seem like they want to
tell it's the best time to tell yeah now
is like get a tattooed on your face yeah
call me by my my gay name right although
honestly it seems like that like the gay
thing doesn't get you as much points as
like the some other things that you
could do
sexually i'm sure i mean i was just
thinking today of like she-hulk
it's like we have hulk and she-hulk it's
like why is everything so binary why
can't we have they-hulk
where's them hulk z-hulk
zim hulk
what's next sheena age mutant ninja
turtles
thank you i'm gonna be doing that on
stage tomorrow night
at the tampa improv open mic
so if you like
if you like cheap half-baked jokes
that crush with jake over here i almost
forgot yeah it's more like jake world oh
wow oh nice there's so much meaning dude
and keep listening to the rest of this
podcast
if you haven't tuned out already
congratulations yeah you get a free rug
from smug rugs smug rugs that says
sheena mutant ninja turtles that would
be can somebody please animate that you
have fans yeah you have you have more
fans than me buy a lot it's not even
close we're gonna
no you you look like the last member of
bts like on an exchange program they're
like okay he was in five seconds of
summer but honestly i don't even know
about bts but i feel like that was a
good joke because i liked your other
jokes so you look like it could be
vaguely like i don't know any ethnicity
you could star in aladdin
okay yeah dude what are you i'm
white just straight up yeah german
german maybe some german well you gotta
you got a hair thing going on i do have
that's vaguely european well a lot of
people maybe it's just um
what's it called hygiene yeah yeah
european soccer hair yeah you have
european soccer oh you're wearing a gold
chain come on you can't just be straight
up white you're a towel yeah but it's
gold-plated it's gold-plated real gold
cheese but if any gold necklace company
wants to sponsor
i get a lot of targeted ads for king ice
i've never bought what's nice it's like
fake jewelry
it's like do you want a a goku head
covered in fake diamonds and i'm like i
do they'll last ten days but i'll turn
up green and starts to smell yeah it's
not like a penny i would love to have
that [ __ ] when i was a little kid i had
a jordan logo covered in fake diamonds
that's pretty sick yeah i could see that
looking really uh
it was really great yeah yeah you seem
like the person see look jordan when
they're worn down i play ball in my tens
yeah also j is the sound letter of the
alphabet oh two tens jj it all makes
sense wow you're making a lot of
connections numerology's never even
heard you're trying to sleep with
crystal chicks are you an astrologist
yeah no i don't know anything about the
stars but my house is full of crystals
i do
smoke weed
through um
there's a thing called mouthpiece
everybody should know about this it's a
filter that you smoke weed through and
it's helped a lot i think also don't use
lighters smoke with wick because lighter
fluid is bad for you
smoke with a bong it's good to filter it
through water less carcinogens
and um yeah those are about the best
tips i can give you probably in life it
feels like there's a lot of uh you might
be overthinking something that's
supposed to just be fun and a little bit
unhealthy like yeah you say that and
then you die in two months from lung
cancer so it's all fun and games until
you're on the gurney yeah but is it fun
and games to have to you know plan out
smoking no to this tea life's not fun
you'll learn that
i'm 32 all right
i look like i'm i'm your older brother
or something like i'm gonna
be i'm the guy patrolling the house
party yeah i'm like all right just
[ __ ] don't go near the window you're
the guy patrolling when the bang bus
pulls up
i have those those
light up things it's banging an airplane
i'm waving in the [ __ ] plane waving
him towards a woman's vagina when's that
gonna happen bang airplane they have
enough money right porn's a trillion
dollar business buy bang airplane i want
everybody [ __ ] in that dude that's
such a good idea yeah but what about the
turbulence if you are out there banging
like you [ __ ]
they're [ __ ] harder
so why do you [ __ ] so loud
i it wasn't me it was the girl just
making noise oh nice
you must be doing a really good job
i think i am yeah i i always think about
doing porn i'm always like if any of you
guys want to have sex with john jacobs
dude please the second my bank account
runs out i'm doing porn
dude i think about doing porn when my
check engine light comes on yeah i'm
like
for this
oh yeah anytime there's any financial
struggle i'm like yeah i should just
spread my ass cheeks open on instagram
let someone check your engine i feel
like if i had an only fans it would be
astronomically more popular than my
stand-up you could combine them you
could kind of like sit in front of a
camera and jerk off and tell your jokes
kind of like i do have to show it but if
we were both i do have a dream i'd like
to speak into existence i i do
unorthodox stand-up specials and uh you
can see all of them on my youtube but
one of them i want to do in the future
is i would love to do a stand-up special
while having sex with a girl on stage
that would be great dude no one's like
jimmy car
you could microphone
that's yeah yeah yeah i'm gonna think
about that yeah one of the jimmy car
mics and you know she's just like on a
table yeah late in front of me did she
consent of course what are you talking
about
you don't know you don't know i don't
know it was our first time
oh my god it's because you're young
that's what you guys are into
consent
no not consent i don't know
young people have weird fetishes i'm not
young i'm a grown man no i feel like
i've always thought once you turn like
35
that's when you're just a straight up
adult yeah at least in entertainment
because i i like to still think i'm like
a youngish comic what's the age where no
one would be impressed by an
accomplishment of yours anymore like if
you got
nobody's impressed right now if but if
you were if you were to get like a a big
let's say netflix special blue and
you're like i'm only i'm only 32. i was
able to like what's that number well i'd
like to think people would be impressed
no matter what age i got a stand-up
special on netflix that's true but you
know if you're like well i guess because
i've been doing it a while if i got a
stand-up special at
55 or 60
people would be like okay you've been
doing stand-up for 30 years yeah you
probably should have had this by now
just give it to them people would be
like it's more awkward that you don't
just give it to me oh yeah i mean even
right now is is brutal telling people
how long i've been doing stand up i'll
do shows and people like oh how long
have you been doing stand-up and i'll be
like almost 15 years now they'll be like
oh
that's the funniest on kill tony when
you're watching and the person bombs and
and tony or the comedian's like is this
your first time yeah and they're like
that's like six years yeah many many
years oh [ __ ] yeah so it is funny doing
like shitty bar open mics and shows or
whatever and i say 15 years ago jesus
but are there are those still like fun
to you are what what is your
what do you get excited for nowadays
doing it 15 years is every time you go
on stage still the same pop
internally or like what do you what do
you seek out now i get to do college
shows those are fun for me because i
like i mean they pay you a lot of money
and you get to travel somewhere and just
do like one show so that's nice i like
yeah i like those because those are easy
to understand local local [ __ ]
of course nice but um
i got excited for uh doing shows with
like
big names who i'm a fan of
yeah like you saw me at big j yeah yeah
i was just about to say that yeah he saw
me open for big j that was my fourth
weekend with big j
and uh yeah i got excited working with
people i'm fans of i mean i've gotten to
work with a lot of my heroes over the
years like anthony jesselnick doug
stanhope nick swardson kevin nealen
recently
but yeah just a list of pablo francisco
was like the first person i ever got to
open up for and i was such a huge fan of
his but yeah like i've gotten to work
with most of my heroes and it's been
pretty cool has there ever been a time
where it's like don't meet your heroes
they really oh yeah and i can't talk
about it but there was a hero who took
me on the road with him
and he just
was a complete psychopath really just a
wild drunk and just abusive
to me verbally wow in general just
really mean
and it broke my heart because i was a
huge fan yeah and i grew up watching him
on tv loving him and then to have him
just like
just be mean to me for no reason too it
was all his own like drunken delusion
so that was a shame and
you know and i've tried to mend it with
him and there's been opportunities but
he just seems to refuse to want to have
any relationship with him it was burke
no
but it but the guy who it is other
people have had similar experiences and
he is like a known psychopath drunk so
isn't that
i couldn't even imagine like
because they're in like the dominant
role over you like you're opening for
them i couldn't even imagine what i
would do hearing people like
a hero like that just berate me verbally
like dude what it was very
like what's the problem yeah it made no
sense
i i'd done nothing wrong and uh
just something was it was you know it's
his own maybe you were [ __ ] too loud
i was i was [ __ ] too loud it was
ruined i was ruining his life
wow good call back yeah this kind of
comedy yeah he did stand up too yeah you
didn't stand up for a few weeks right
yeah i might be there tomorrow oh yeah
how long did you do
16 years probably like
two to three years up to the pandemic
and then okay and then during the
pandemic move to tampa and then lost all
of my like known stages to go to
just now go to the improv whenever i can
but it's like am i gonna go to the
improv and and talk to 12 people that
are all half checking their notes and
half not paying attention and wait three
hours or am i going to keep editing a
video that a bunch of people are going
to enjoy nowadays like i just want to be
involved with comedy and sometimes it's
like oh [ __ ] like i love getting on
stage and it usually goes pretty well
because i'm not
doing anything new sure
um it's like you know the give and take
sometimes for me is like i'd rather get
another video up get the dopamine of all
these these views then yeah go talk into
a
bottomless pit
right now yeah you uh you decided to
quit comedy and be successful
unbelievable
yeah that's yeah that's usually so i
don't do it enough to really call myself
a comedian by any means but i will
occasionally
i mean i love to get up there and do the
same five minutes i've been doing for
the past two years yeah i feel like you
look vaguely familiar so i feel like
i've seen you at the improv probably
yeah probably what's your last name from
bach oh jesus yeah jacob from bach
do you want to hear my my opening joke
of course this is a lot of pressure
because i know
you might bomb to your yeah your camera
this would be really embarrassing to my
camera no all right ready i'll enjoy it
i'm sure
chase it's kind of like you you got it
is it performative yeah
you're cutting your head off yeah oh
yeah we don't want
yeah you seem real nervous this is
realistic this is make or break it's
realistic
it's hard for me to buy clothes because
i'm 6'3 but i only weigh 80 pounds
if i describe my body type i'd say i
look like the best player on the
auschwitz basketball team
i'm just kidding i'm just kidding i'm 90
german
so i played shooting guard hey
that's pretty good shirts and skin and
bones
that's nice two tags on there yeah two
tabs i liked it because at first it
seemed like a little cheap joke of just
saying auschwitz basketball team you go
okay yeah but then uh shooting guard is
funny thank you and then sure yeah
skin and bones thank you amazing so it
was great i loved it yeah thank you
i have one question for you that i wrote
down before only one interview pressure
sure please i did an extensive
background search yeah you didn't even
know i was on tv right yeah and uh and
this is really the main thing i want to
know about you is
so for me growing up with the name jacob
whenever i heard that little fake what
is a fairy tale or a rhyme about john
jacob
yeah whenever i heard that and they'd
say jake if i get excited i'd be like
let's go they put jacob in but for you
it's taken to a whole nother level
because you have john and jacob yeah the
whole beginning yeah you're not you
don't jingleheimer smith do you have a
no that's not me okay so
how is that like growing up hearing that
little rhyme that little ditty what how
do you think that molded you into who
you are today oh i'd say that's probably
most of the reason i do stand up because
all of my first interactions with people
especially as a child was through that
and it's also very strange for people to
sing at you strangers
because singing is like an intimate
thing most people go i don't want to
sing i don't sing i don't sing but for
me everyone i met would sing at me like
in in like a mocking tone or whatever
and you know
yeah yeah and i'd just be like oh yeah
you know it's been yeah and everybody
would go where are you named after that
no i don't think so they go really and i
go yeah i don't think i was named after
that and they'd go what were your
parents thinking and i go i don't know
i guess you were thinking kids aren't
[ __ ] baby yeah but yeah i was named
after my uncle john and it's funny
because even my dad recently i was
hanging out with him and i go and i said
something like yeah you know growing up
with like a name that people would make
fun of and joke about was interesting
and he goes what are you talking about
and i go john jacobs he goes what he go
i go there's the song john jacob jingle
hammer schmidt he goes people don't
actually
mention that do they they go yeah my
whole life
and he goes nah i don't i don't think so
and i i don't think so i go yeah who
would who would know better yeah of
having the name john jacob he's just
deciding yeah no yeah he's like no i
can't be i'm like yeah literally right
so even recently i had a cashier like
cvs just go is this your real name
and i'm like yeah it's on the credit
card like but i go yeah it's my real
name like wow
like yes it's insane that's kind of
a lot from the cvs employee like it's
not that unbelievable yeah it's not that
crazy if you were john jacob
jingleheimer yeah that would be a little
but it's not that crazy yeah but that
definitely
shaped my comedic whatever and um and
it's it's funny too because like
you know the lyrics of the song and all
that it's like you know his name is my
name too like this oh yeah this
literally is a song about my life and
you know whenever we go out the people
always shout that's kind of scary
that's an aggressive like that's i have
paranoia and maybe that's why but
whenever we go out the people always
shout right now i mean it's you know
maybe i'm like a rock star i'm like
elvis or something but they just shout
just
not a word they just shout yeah they
just shout
and then this song just repeats over and
over and over again i kind of have a um
over the last few years you know when
you you mentioned being like
they're like oh that's so funny you're
like huh yeah yeah
every time that i'll meet a stranger or
when i had the sales job and would call
and be like this and i'd have to say
this is jake or i introduce myself as
jake everyone wants to be like
are you jake from state farm oh that's
always like i was hoping to say that
that's that's a good thing are you jake
from state farm a lot of people say that
all the time that's fun and that's
probably a common jake issue it's not as
customized as yours but it's it's not
funny to hear that all the time or ever
and it's just like uh
yeah no i have a good uh experience
that's happened a million times so i've
run a ton of comedy shows on my own like
open mics or one-nighters where i have
to promote on the street like i'll be an
e-board barking with flyers beforehand
to get people in and when i tell people
there's a stand-up comedy show the most
common responses i'll hear from people
one i'll go i'll say oh do you guys like
stand-up comedy sam comedy show they'll
go uh we like sit down comedy and
they'll like laugh at that another one
uh hey you guys want to see a stand-up
comedy show oh we've got all the comedy
with this guy over here he's enough
comedy for it
yeah so those are the two most common
responses i'll just say tell me a joke
be funny whatever
and like sometimes i'll dance for them
and you know tell them a joke but it's
awful dude
well another thing that you probably get
all the time
and i get less back in the day when i'm
like yeah i'm going to do comedy stand
up whatever is uh oh
you do you do stand up or you're a
comedian tell me a joke right now yeah
that's i hate i don't even like telling
people that i have a youtube channel or
anything
i hate it like i try to not mention it
to people at this point yeah anytime
people ask what i do i'll usually just
say like video work yeah cause like yeah
i do video stuff like yeah do video work
whatever let me know
yeah that's not a lie
but is there a response that you have
can't have you ever actually went
through with telling a joke because i
feel like that's got to be suicide to
tell oh
it's kind of like what i just did right
here i'm still reeling no for sure from
my experience and now you did great we
loved it
but no i've had to tell jokes many times
i mean you know if you're
if you're trying to have sex with
somebody sure
if it's a beautiful person you go all
right fine or if it's like someone
valuable who could
invest in your career or whatever dummy
joke
fine
but um yeah for the most part i just
don't tell a joke or i just go no i go
[ __ ] you i'm not working right now give
me a break yeah it's even worse
sometimes they don't say tell me a joke
sometimes they'll just go be funny
that's so that's like rude and it's
awful be funny do something funny you
know i like when uh sometimes it like
bars or
places where you know girls or people
interact sometimes girls would come up
to me if they'll like recognize me from
mtv or something and they'll be like so
like you probably think you're like
really cool or whatever because you do
your little show or whatever girls love
to use little to just yeah degrade
whatever it is yeah you like your little
skits yeah your little dick so what you
do stand up so like you do your little
shows or whatever i'm like they're big
shows
they're big venues yeah
yeah no so that's interesting that for
some and like people will say this to me
so like you probably think you're like
cool because you are on tv or whatever
i'm like you walked up to me yeah i
didn't i didn't come over to you what
the [ __ ] do you want
clearly i am cool if you know
first of all yeah sometimes another good
one is people will be like yeah my like
my friend watches your show i don't
watch that stuff that's like oh cool
thanks
now now you're yeah now i think you're
really awesome yeah because you said
i'll watch that oh cool yeah me neither
dude [ __ ] that [ __ ]
yeah could i talk to your friends yeah
like call your friends yeah
i mean i love when people say nice
things i love positive attention but you
know you you don't always get that i get
a lot of i mean i don't get a lot i'd
say maybe
i don't know 20 of my comments are
negative on my content do you think that
you're cool because you only follow one
person on instagram yes yeah i don't
care about anybody that's why
what do i want to see i want to see your
[ __ ] babies or whatever look at my
baby look at my brunch so look at my hat
during my prep on your instagram which
was my big research today i did see some
uh man on the street stuff in ebore yes
that looked pretty entertaining and i'm
curious about it because like that seems
so much um
scarier than stand up because stand up
you're in a room where everyone's agreed
to hear some jokes yeah they're good or
bad they might bomb whatever they're
interested in comedy standing out on the
corner and especially in all places ybor
city just like
trying to roast people yeah
how did you
come up with that idea does it always go
well do you have any um
exciting stories from being out on the
street well my first like public
stand-up performances in a
unconventional place was i made a movie
called plane train
there's a there's a train at the airport
at tampa airport that's a five-minute
ride that goes from the rental cars to
the terminal and uh the airport gave me
permission to do stand-up on it all day
long oh that's why i made a movie out of
it and uh that was pretty intense and
fun and then i was like but so i made
this movie and uh somebody put it on
reddit and a lot of people were trashing
me i didn't want to go look but
eventually i looked at a few of the
comments and a lot of people were
trashing me like oh it's a captive
audience you know this guy sucks he's no
good uh you know he wouldn't do this in
the streets like he wouldn't do this in
public somebody beat his ass i'd punch
him in the face if i saw him doing this
[ __ ] this guy so i was like okay they
don't think i'll do this in a more
intense location
oh dude it makes no sense but people
yeah people are taking it personally
that i'm doing stuff free clean stand-up
show yeah on a train at an airport what
the [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] this people just want
to go to their plane they're still yeah
oh yeah i think there's going to be a
lot of time yeah
so yeah so then the next one i started
doing street [ __ ] and i was like yeah
let's see nobody's gonna [ __ ] i'll
prove it's working and it went great you
know i get a lot of good responses or
not but yeah there's something about
performing on the street which i don't
know yeah is it working yeah okay good
yeah none of this is recorded but it
does feel more uh
i don't know feels more pure and there
is less pressure because it is the thing
too of like if you can do well on the
street when nobody's expecting anything
and nobody really wants it either then
you're good if you can make something
out of nothing literally create an
atmosphere from nowhere then i feel like
you have something special and then it
feels no stakes because if something
misses uh i'm not in a comedy club right
i'm not getting paid there's nothing on
the line here people are walking past me
anyway yeah nobody's really gonna just
sit there and be mad at me if they don't
like it just keep [ __ ] walking so
yeah i had a lot of fun with that and
plus it's like i realize i've come to
accept that i may not be the greatest
comedian in the world ever
like i when i was young i'd like to
think i could be the greatest of all
time i still believe in you uh-huh thank
you and i like maybe maybe one day but
i've come to accept okay i'm probably
not the greatest joke writer on earth
i'm not the smartest person on earth i'm
not the most clever person on earth but
what are my strengths i go okay i'll put
myself in situations that other people
won't
so whereas most people would be
intimidated by performing in
uncomfortable spots like on the street
or on a train or whatever i'm fine with
this so i go okay i might not be the
funniest comedian in the world but i
might be the funniest comedian hung up
on a cross dressed like jesus doing
stand up which is my newest special hung
up on the cross it's called dying on the
cross and i'm dressed up as jesus it's a
follow-up to my first jesus stand-up
special called jesus talks
so yeah this one's called dying on the
cross it's unbelievable it's amazing
clean did it in public yeah it sounds
clean and i know i i hung myself up on a
10-foot cross on easter yeah and
just
killed
i killed yeah i know i told the story of
the crucifixion
with jokes
and it's it's beautiful and i'm so happy
with it
i've always life thought that the story
of the crucifixion did not have enough
humor not enough punchlines yeah it was
pretty grim right drab it was a sad
story
but no yeah so i spice it up but you
know by just breaking down what was
going on yeah what was going on
a lot actually
something i did learn during my research
of jesus doing this movie
um
i googled because jesus was a teacher
before he started doing the whole like
i'm god thing did he go to school for
that he did go to school to become a
teacher which he dropped out of but um
he became like a you know like a
religious teacher at the temples and i
googled when was the first day jesus was
a teacher
first day jesus was ever a teacher
9 11.
yep look it up
so that kind of like you know that makes
more sense yeah they would do it on 9 11
to really yeah they want to change
yeah they want to change the tone of
that day yeah to be negative only and
ruin his teaching anniversary exactly
because they probably had some sort of
like break room event for like happy
you know 2008 years of teaching jesus
like there's a cake and uh oh no what's
going on in new york i know yeah kind of
thing brutal but they got him
vagina 11.
i always thought that was funny that's
what that's what it was every day for
leticia above me
vagina
poor lady
she left i hope she's doing good
louder than the real 911 maybe we'll
meet one day again yeah but louder than
the real 911 oh
yeah somebody was going down oh man i'm
gonna get cancelled terrible
it's okay i have nothing to lose already
dude something that i like i've got
again about your instagram is uh it
seems like half the reels you post
and for some reason this just makes me
laugh so hard is like
a stand-up clip where the audience is
not giving what you wanted and you're
just like all right guys but i guess
we're done or like you're addressing
like a joke that fell flatter than it
should have and then they laughed so
hard at that and i laugh so hard it's
like so funny to see a canadian just
like
break the
fourth wall or whatever you want to call
it and just be like all right next joke
damn right baby they call me johnny
bounce backs
yeah man my save lines sometimes most of
the times get better responses than the
actual joke which is a shame but no i
i've realized i'm pretty good recovery
i'm very aware
i hate
comics who just power through and don't
address when it's not working i want
everything i say to get some sort of
reaction yeah so if i say something and
it gets nothing i'm gonna be like okay
well sorry for that one like i have to
address it because i feel uncomfortable
because it feels like you're delusional
if you just go through it yeah or just
you memorize something and you're like
i'm not even taking the response to the
crowd i'm just going to get through this
five-minute script that i have
that [ __ ] is terrible oh yeah yeah like
some of my biggest videos it was yeah
there was the emo baby one where i was
like a save line i do i stupid a stupid
impression like it was my impression of
an emo baby
and that got nothing yeah and i go
comedy's about taking risks guys and
then i you know made some riff
that got like four million views
five million views
and uh and yeah i don't get it
i never know what's gonna work i just i
just crank [ __ ] i mean you crank too so
it's like you just throw [ __ ] out maybe
it sticks who knows the internet is
[ __ ] yeah and i'm allowed to say
that i have tourette syndrome you're
allowed to say it but you're not allowed
to say it on the internet no dude
youtube has again been getting so oh
yeah
taken down i said 9 11. i said [ __ ]
i'm done
yeah
they're going to kill me
you're still the little hot boy
yeah
is that why you have fans because you're
a hot boy i don't think so i think it's
because i post famous comedians i
already have a lot of fans no people
probably don't even know who you are
yeah probably not they're like this is
the guy from the logo oh my god it was
definitely like that in the beginning i
feel like we've done i had no idea what
to expect i guess you looked about what
i figured actually because i was like
it's a joke world reference
i mean a juice world reference so he's
probably like
you know some hip kid
people who like juice world are usually
pretty hip
say things like hip am i living up to
your expectations yeah sweet yeah what
kind of sandals are those they're the
rubber barks that i like to wear by
waters jesus they're not those probably
cost more than these
no these are actually only 50 bucks for
the rubber ones but the cork ones are
like can get up to like 110 130. yeah
i've really not worn shoes since i moved
here i have a i put socks on for this
because one time someone's like dude we
don't want to see your toes oh wow so i
put some socks on you don't wear shoes
too much huh no i have a tan line of
birds dude i'd be too nervous and
sandals i'm paranoid i assume anywhere i
go someone's going to attack me that's
ridiculous you know what that's so
ridiculous my the other day i was
talking to my girlfriend she was like oh
i don't like going out with my
sunglasses when it's like six o'clock
because then you have to carry them
around after it gets dark and i want to
put them on my head and if i put them in
my shirt she said she her biggest fear
of why she doesn't want to have her
sunglasses is she puts them in her shirt
she thinks someone's gonna run up to her
yeah steal the sunglasses and then run
away yeah and i'm like that
that's why you don't like bring your
glasses i thought it's because it's
cumbersome and you don't want to put
them in your pockets you don't want to
lose your glasses she thinks that
there's people around that will see you
from afar sprint up to you
take your glasses and then just run what
happens that is the most irrational
stupid fear that's the main reason you
don't want your glasses with you yeah no
i i i think i began being paranoid after
the tv stuff why i did get catfished i
told it on a different podcast you'll
have to see the other podcast for that
but um i there was you know that's kind
of shitty because i don't know the story
i don't i don't know i just i just
and then it was like scary and it like i
felt that i felt i started like getting
stalked and the the the person who
catfished me
started knowing where i was and would
like to text me
i still don't know who it is for sure i
have ideas but i still have no idea oh
so this seems like real oh yeah it was
very real like it's like still like i
mean it happened so long ago that like
it's not a thing now hopefully not ever
again but um yeah that happened and then
like
there'd be times on social media where
people would like post candid pictures
of me which was strange they'd be like
here's john jacobs at a gas station
here's like one time i was like just at
lunch and it was like close to me and
i'm like where the [ __ ] was this person
yeah somebody's like here's john eating
a burrito and i was like what the [ __ ]
so like that made me feel weird a little
bit but you know that was that was a
long time ago and i don't think anybody
cares about me what is this john jacobs
paparazzi content who's this for yeah
who the [ __ ] that's what i'm wondering
who gives a [ __ ] i'm nobody but even
like real paparazzi content of like
kim kardashian eating a burrito
i still don't get really who's who
that's for psychopaths like that's like
the you can at least understand why that
could happen to her i don't get like
that's sometimes people don't believe on
me i was at a i was at a bar one time
and somebody goes you look like that guy
from tv and i go i am him and he goes
nah he wouldn't be here and i go okay
and i go no it's me he goes no he goes
but you could you should say you are
though i'm like do you think if i could
if i would pretend to be somebody i
would pick
a random guy
oh yeah from a reality dating show you
don't think i'd shoot higher no you're
not hey it's me 12 pack from i love new
york like give me a break dude that's
got to be a trip yeah it is fun i mean i
i love you know positive recognition and
i had a guy stop his car
on a
saturday
and middle of the road a guy in a truck
just like slammed on his brakes he saw
me walking and just goes i love your
[ __ ] dude instagram i see your videos i
was like thank you so that's nice
you know what's crazy about that is like
even
like i love your stood on instagram but
even if i was driving and i saw you you
wouldn't
but there would be no way that i would
be like that's definitely him yeah i
know it is
maybe the long hair is even still i know
even still yeah it's tough to just be
100 anybody's anybody but yeah so yeah
if you see me say hi to me
don't kill me
i'm very worried about that
please don't kill him please don't i
know you're not supposed to talk about
negative things because then that gives
it a better chance of happening is that
true yes really i don't know that's what
the internet says like you're only
supposed to talk about good stuff
because then you manifest good things
yeah but isn't that kind of like a crazy
way to live like only talking about good
stuff yes
i don't know
but yeah
but some some people say if you talk
about the bad stuff then you can take
the power away and like realize how
crazy it is yeah but it doesn't sound
any less crazy every time i say it i
kind of just think you talk about stuff
and then you go do your day
sure yeah i mean
nobody knows if anything is real yeah
that's true this whole thing could be
kind of simulated anyway so i mean it's
either something is or isn't gonna
happen it's 50 50. does praying work
does manifesting work maybe there's been
times where i'll ask for stuff and then
something happens so maybe but do you
ask for it and then do nothing
afterwards oh okay
i'll go please have this person call me
or whatever and then they call me i'll
go please let something show up into my
life and then it shows up into my life
kind of like this yeah is this one of
the things i prayed for this
i prayed for joke world
pray to be on episode 12 yeah what's
your favorite juice world song um
i i feel like that was like i don't know
if you're actually interested or yes i
don't like juice my favorite album for
sure is good buying good riddance i like
um
i like lean with me a lot i like you
know what's crazy is i listen to all
these songs and i like know all the
words and then i i if you really think
about the words you're like this doesn't
really relate to me at all but
no i still [ __ ] with it heavy like
you know what the best thing is is juice
world freestyles on youtube i would
recommend that m m ones yeah where you
did all this stuff like two hours
uninterrupted without stuttering and
they're better than most real-time oh
yeah it was pretty insane yeah i mean
obviously there's the 1400 one with
trippy red which is i love that trippy
red's best song
yeah they sound the same which is funny
but um yeah that was great i liked i
like dolls realer and reeler i like that
one too the rich and blind sometimes the
whole thing that he did with uh
with future that mixtape was great sure
i like um i think it's it might have
just been called legends but he's like
uh
something about like
what's the 27 club yeah make it a past
21 and then he died on his 21st birthday
yeah god rappers are just they got to
stop talking about yeah mac died when he
was 26 and he has the line that's like
for everyone who sells me drugs don't
mix it with that [ __ ] and
try and join the 27 club i just spit
that perfectly from my memory and he
died when he was 26. dude pop smoke has
a song called invincible which came out
one month after he died
i love it have you heard the the post
i think they're called post-mortem
albums from juice there's so many of
them that are like talking about pills
pills pills but that would be fine i
think i'm gonna be
[Music]
like he has lyrics that are like if i
ever overdosed my my girl would be so
mad oh yeah like his mom being upset
yeah yeah well you know he it's he
didn't die from the pills he died from
getting scared when the cops showed up
that's what it was honestly i can't like
max it's anxious
and you're like okay that was really sad
and whatever but juice is just sometimes
pissed me off because i'm like that was
you're so rich you know you can get
oh yeah no yeah he brought all that weed
on his plane and but yeah i think just
the nerves of having your plane
surrounded by police and having them
storm your plane yeah yeah he that like
that put him into the scene for sure
like and yeah obviously the drugs didn't
help because i heard that he started
trying to take
some of like a bunch of them so he
wouldn't there wouldn't be as much
evidence but then i heard that he also
had like a pound of oxy with him so i'm
like even if you have
so i don't understand what your logic is
here yeah
so one of the rumors i don't know how
training this was but they you know they
said he started doing rehab just so he
could like lo lowers tolerance again
they're like he didn't actually want to
stop he just wanted to take a break so
he could break up
yeah yeah uh yeah
but yeah he was a star and it was sad
but live on forever there's still
there's still good
juice world music coming out now because
he recorded so many songs i heard his
song on dj khaled's new album i did not
hear that juice did they didn't believe
in us god did i know which is what the
such a weird that was the most annoying
it's like oh
you suck does anyone like him who dj
khaled i can't imagine
dj khaled always reminded me of like the
guy who organizes the pickup basketball
game
and then he doesn't score but his team
wins but he just celebrates yeah he
celebrates hard we won y'all we won it's
like yeah he didn't make one shot barely
gets up and down the court yeah well i
called everybody to bring him here two
knee braces ankle braces and he'll take
one contested layup that goes over the
other side of the hoop air ball up and
then one three where he [ __ ] it all the
way behind his head oh yeah yeah 100
yeah he's at this point he's basically
just like
it might as well be called the
illuminati mix tape
because it's just
yeah the the pairings don't even make
sense anymore no it's like we got the
baby with billy eilish yeah saying okay
yeah did we need this it's literally
like he's making a click bait song oh
yeah it's click bait songs kanye west
and eminem and tupac and they're sick
and they're so bad though it's so bad
yeah it's because there's no feeling in
any of it and he used to be on like
pretty popular songs when he would like
drake albums and stuff i liked his miami
stuff yeah
but then it seems like he got to a point
where i don't know anyone else
his whole job is just to yell their name
at the beginning of the song to disney
world yeah he's just he's a mascot
he's a [ __ ] rap mascot
literally uh yeah rap mascot but i think
he's a cringy one at that i don't know
many mascots that aren't
kind of cringey but he is yeah he is i
mean it feels it feels a little bit
strange when he says the n-word he says
a plenty and it's like dude you're
iranian yeah like
what
and
you're you almost seem like not even a
person anyway you seem like a
corporation almost like a business so
that's almost like a business
is like you should lose rap music yeah
yeah his yeah they should put khaled
albums in happy meals
i would love to meet
i if i saw him i'd be like i'm such a
fan i would never say any of this to him
well yeah which is most yeah which is
most of life and most people would never
say any nonsense they say to celebrities
to their face but i don't get why that's
bad honestly like to trash people to try
to trash millionaires like dj khaled and
not say anything even really too
personal like we didn't call him a fat
ass or anything no um
like why is that bad dude he's never
gonna see this he's never going to care
well you don't know and he's never he
might hurt his feelings
he maybe he's googling juice world and
this pops up trying to get him on the
next clip oh [ __ ] joke world okay they
didn't believe in us joke world
yeah
but i don't believe in him so yeah i
wonder yeah he seems yeah it is like a
cartoon i can't imagine spending a day
with him no he just seems like a lot
that's what i was going to say that's
why i don't feel bad about calm down
yeah i wouldn't have a good like he
could take me he's obviously very
wealthy has a lot of resources he could
kill both of us
yeah by falling on us ah that [ __ ]
dumpster
i love you i love you vj khaled
v d khalid
from ariel's disease
he's good i like him he's all right
he looks like he would be in the movie
taken buying one of the girls
[Music]
buying two or three of the girls yeah
y'all coming with me
y'all are mine now i'm trying to think
of uh popular what is this i'm trying to
think of some good catchphrases i'm
drawing them blank
get her done what
that's the perfect example of
manifesting
he just said it enough times came true
now he's there we're the best no we're
the best all right fine we you win the
best we give up you are the yeah it's
like a little kid when you just go sure
you are you're the best
but he's not the best and all of his
music sucks
yeah well you know
the world needs a punching bag too
that's true we we love having people we
can trash on and you know if it wasn't
true well here's a fun story
um circling back to 9 11. i'm glad that
we could get back there because i was i
was thinking
yeah yeah i know pop some champagne
but um so
dj khaled his original dj name was going
to be arab
terror yes
but then 9 11 happened
and he changed it to dj khaled
so right when you think 911 can't get
any worse
it creates dj khaled holy [ __ ] yeah no
if those planes didn't hit those
buildings we wouldn't have god did
well
[ __ ] 911 just got so much worse i know
never forget
i know i wonder if anybody's going to be
mad at this content
i don't know are 9 11 jokes okay yet has
it been long enough
um
i don't think anyone will get too upset
we don't really people probably won't
make it this far and that's true if
you're still listening you've already
accepted that
yeah unless they because i'd like to do
those little things underneath the time
stamps so maybe they thought this was
going to be some quality content then
they're like what do they have to say
about dj khaled i'm going to be a fan of
this podcast is the equivalent of a dj
khaled
yeah that's
packed full of stars
but
empty and worth it doesn't really make
much sense no
no no no heart no soul no
but just flashy dude i had something to
say before this oh darn totally free
always really good the thing you forgot
yeah it would have been really funny too
it would have been so you would have
laughed earlier damn it i know i know i
would have
we're just killing it right now i know
oh yeah i think people are at home like
i think this is pretty enjoyable people
are going all right yeah i think so i'm
having a good time i know if one day
maybe the world will agree one day i
don't know i also remembered what i was
going to say but it's not fun
it's kind of insightful but nothing even
worth saying but i'm gonna say yeah yeah
yeah um talking about people being like
i wonder if they'll be okay with this
content yeah
uh purposefully everything
that i've ever posted
has been in my stream of like sense of
humor
so if you're around this channel at all
you've heard
joey diaz say some terrible things on
some of my videos you've heard
you know the kind of content that's
surrounding the channel in the first
place with the popular comedians that i
like to make edits of
we couldn't really even say anything
that could raise some eyebrows that's
good then yeah yeah i mean i have a lot
of doubt all the time because like i
like to think i'm good at what i do but
then i think you're good at what you 50
of the time i just go oh they're just
gonna look at me and hate me they're
just gonna go [ __ ] this kid
and i don't know why
just in my head for some reason i go
they're gonna look at me and go he's a
fraud he's not
good at comedy
and
i'm gonna kill him now damn dude you are
worried about getting murdered i know i
don't know why maybe i listened to too
much scary music growing up do you
listen to scary music well i mean when i
was like a real little kid
like a real
dmx was like my favorite oh yeah up
until i was like 14 15 years old i
really thought the only paths in life
were like prison or gang i liked dmx for
the homophobia
yeah he's yeah how you gonna explain
[ __ ] a man even if we squash the beef
i ain't touching your hand
he won't touch your hand if you have
guys
and everyone wants dmx to gently embrace
their hand and come on dmx
that is funny because
uh i also am a rap fan and yeah you
really
they uh paint this beautiful picture of
a life of
this awful lot
that wasn't like real yeah i mean at
least for you know
a white kid yeah most of the time
but
yeah
most of us but yeah like as a little kid
all i listened to was rap music which
i don't know how that happened my older
brother likes rap liked rap music and
you know you just follow whatever your
older sibling does
so i only listened to rap music and it's
still pretty much like that so yeah i
had no idea that i just i was like oh
yeah you know you get older and then gun
fights happen and then you get that's
what happens yeah and you're plus your
boys die
so you go okay it's really happening to
them so it's probably going to happen to
me but yeah i've realized that i'm not
in a gang and that's not a life i live
but i still have
paranoia and fear yeah yeah maybe if
everything goes well with this podcast
maybe i'll i'll be getting a call from
maybe someone will reach out from a gang
probably dj khaled they'll probably ask
me if i want to do
every song on his next album
from the terror group what
what i know what a good name that is a
great name it is a good name
um
yeah how would that sound like before
he never would have been famous at all
no chance that would have been popular
or he would have been famous for being
like [ __ ] this guy like before we even
got famous just like it would have been
the same feelings we have now but yeah
but back then back then yeah there never
would have been the the grace period and
we'd actually have a reason to hate them
yeah one more
yoinks yeah yeah right row man my my
stage name is al qaeda
so
albert cade albert cada the third have
you ever thought about having a stage
name no
everybody already thinks my name's a
stage team is john jacobs your real name
yeah you didn't make that up for the
show now have you ever thought about
like maybe starting off when you started
putting um clips and stuff out have you
ever thought like
all the people that you've met
previously in your life whether it be
school or whatnot and your actual family
members oh i don't i might want to do
some comedy that i don't want people to
actually know me to see so i want to
like i wish this wasn't my like well i
mean i didn't put up clips till i had
been doing stand-up for like seven years
so i waited until i thought i was decent
anyway to post stuff so
i wouldn't embarrass myself like plus i
wouldn't post anything that i
wasn't like getting a good reaction or i
thought was funny so but maybe just like
the topics like if you're talking about
like like loud [ __ ] and then you're
like i mean i went first
for the first few weeks
did you really
yeah
do you remember what it was arab terror
damn it you walked right in here you
should have seen that one coming yep
just like the planes oh no dude another
good one terrible we're really you're
really crushing it i'm trying dc gets no
love for 911. because that's where i'm
from and nobody cares about dc on n11
the pentagon got hit that's because that
one was fake and there's no videos
exactly there's there's 200 cameras
pointing at the pentagon and all we have
is this little blurry image of something
blowing missile yeah yeah that's why
dude how about how about okay when i was
in high school they took us from
cleveland ohio to
the well we drove to dc but on the way
there we stopped at that uh flight 92
memorial in pennsylvania field yeah
whatever there's a whole memorial and
like this big expensive center and then
the the mark where it was hit and this
beautiful like yeah thing to everyone
that died and then a few years ago they
come out and they're just like
yeah we had we shot that one down it was
head for the white house that whole
story is fake they shot it down it
confirmed what thing that the the flight
that they were like let's roll and they
use the car and all that stuff
they shot they shot that down over
pennsylvania because it was heading
towards the white house and it's just so
insane the hell it's insane i wish we
had a producer i just learned to be like
that wow yeah look that up yeah hey look
that up girlfriend with the face
girlfriend with the long hair she's over
in the corner she's just naked
i told her i was like she's spreading
eagle for me yeah and just licking her
legs on my rider that has to happen
wherever i go or i won't perform i was
like could you please do my podcast
please your girlfriend has to be there
yeah you had to beg her to do yeah well
not too hard she was a fan yeah
but she thought khalid was coming you
said arab terror was coming she was like
and she was like oh now i'll do this so
they shot that plane down yeah then
tried to feed us a story of patriotism
that's like yeah i thought they they
were banned together
which i would never say in public and i
feel like i have to now mm-hmm it's so
terrible it's the worst one we're not in
public we're just not just nobody yeah
and your naked girlfriend i wanted to
say if 911 taught us anything it's that
three out of four planes are full of
cowards
[Music]
because yeah you know they made it seem
like oh one plane stopped them yeah they
stopped them
they did they loved their country they
did
do you saw
mark wahlberg said if he was on the
plane it wouldn't happen
why he was supposed to be on one of the
planes so was uh the family guy yeah
both of them so mark wahlberg was
supposed to be on one of those planes
and he has said in openly on interviews
if i was on the plane it wouldn't have
happened
he would have stopped him
[Music]
i gotta leave now yeah you [ __ ] you
took it too far
all right if mark wahlberg was there
let's say if mark wahlberg was there
what is he doing you think to just what
are you what are you doing
yo are you trying to take over the plane
you own my plane man
i made
entourage did he make android it's
supposed to be based on him huh you know
that huh yeah he made entourage and it's
supposed to be based on his life which
is great i've never seen entourage so i
might not be able to contribute too much
to this conversation
thank you for saying that's terrible
because there's so many pieces
pieces there's so many people in my life
trying to tell me to eat at wall burgers
to watch entourage and i don't want to
watch it who would say that dude my
roommate friends ears my roommate always
says well you do have
lights around you you have to watch it
my [ __ ] my stupid girlfriend she's
always like entourage was the best show
i've ever seen
um some other people have said it and uh
basically
an entire show
based around
the beginning scenes in porn
like that fake interaction and porn
before they [ __ ] that's every episode
okay that's the kind of acting that's
the story well i do like um
watching porn for fun sometimes then
i'll turn it off when they start having
sex because i those scenes can sometimes
be very interesting like the situations
that they're in are so
uh extreme that's it's some of the best
content after i've run through my
instagram reels and some youtube shorts
i'll usually go to pornhub and just see
you know if i can find a good storyline
and then obviously turn it off when they
get to the
inappropriate part my favorite porn
finale ending of a movie was uh the
woman was a meter maid i guess
and uh the guy had had sex with her and
finished on her face
and she stands up and goes
so anyways you're still double parked
there's one guy that watches this that
the whole time he's jerking he's like
hey that's better he's still double
parked
don't forget about yeah but like yeah i
think i think we've all checked out at
that point
but so yeah oh yeah congratulations yeah
yeah congrats for making it to the end
of this podcast yeah
true that's that's
that's a way bigger uh yeah
accomplishment
a couple times
but that's understandable i mean you
can't talk about 911 without getting a
little bit there's no way that anyone
made it start to finish of this episode
yeah without jerking off my motto is
live every day like it's 9 10.
the day of peace
things were different things were much
different on 9 10.
it's kind of unfortunate that i have
no um
like i was what three years old when
that happened i don't i have no memory
of it so it's like way more it's super
easy to joke about i feel like because
i'm very
clear memories about it the 90s for me
were all a blur honestly sure well it
didn't happen in the 90s i know but i'm
saying before that like being born in 98
and then just getting tonight i had no
skin in the game really i didn't even
know what country i was living
yeah yeah so yeah what's a plane yeah
what airplanes was the world trade
center no yeah yeah yeah that you were
more pure yeah you weren't corrupted yet
no
so that's why it's like
okay one bad day at the office for those
people
my favorite story of 911 there's a lot
to pick from but um one guy
he got he got caught cheating on his
wife yeah because he worked in one of
the world trade centers and he was with
another woman at the time and his wife
calls him and goes oh my god are you
okay
and he didn't know what happened he's
with the girl and he goes
yeah i'm just at the office what's up
um
on the news yeah clearly he was not at
the office i love that
that sucks that's good uh
well like what a way to get caught yeah
what a way to get caught you're talking
about worrying about stuff imagine if
you were trying to cheat on your
girlfriend and you're like she's gonna
just think well to be fair the cheating
did save his life true if he didn't
cheat he would have been at the office
he would have been screwed and that's
something that i would like everyone to
take with it
is that uh
cheat more often or else you might be
uh killed and killed in a terrorist
attack yeah yeah well thank you so much
john jacobs for stopping by this was a
very fun to visit joke world educational
episode i think i learned a lot
about life and about comedy yeah it was
an honor i can't wait to be canceled for
numerous reasons
i can't wait to lose whatever future
deals i could have made yeah i was gonna
talk to you after this about like
hopefully i'm gonna try to find a clip
to promote our episode on instagram
maybe become a collaborator but after
after thinking
running back this in my head i don't
think there's anything that we could uh
from this from this that we're going to
be able to post on instagram so yeah we
found this episode uh through youtube
yeah if you yeah if you cut
the
the controversial stuff out of this
episode it'll be about three minutes
long
so which is going to be the average view
duration anyway so exactly yeah
i will be
pleasantly surprised if people break the
three minute mark cause they'll go well
i don't know him why am i watching this
who the [ __ ] is this kid
where's juice world they probably think
this is like an affiliate some people
will com you know what my favorite
comments are is like i love comedy and i
love juice 999 what a good combo but
then some people will be like
wow really really shitty that you're
just taking
his name and and stuff like that and
i've never thought about it like that at
all right i think this is a way to honor
one of my favorite musicians yeah keep
the wrld acronym moving forward i
changed the first part obviously and the
outro song is always one of his
instrumentals so it's those people i
don't really
how else would you want me to honor the
man yeah my comedy channel is called
plop smoke
and it's uh
it's a it's a site where we take dumps
and um
you know we smoke afterwards yeah xxx
uh
xxx some jokes temptations it's a it's a
singing group little tweet oh my
god little yeah what's a little peep
little p poor poor guy so many rappers
who just
love fentanyl
all right that's it thanks peace out
guys smoke fentanyl you can actually do
that try it try it out try smoking
fentanyl right now
blast off in the comments how you feel
we're not leaving until i see you do
[ __ ] no i can see through the camera you
people don't know that if you look hard
enough into the camera you can see the
audience watching it that's true yeah so
uh you know crush up your adderall snort
it do you want to plug any um any of
your socials or do you think happens
yeah my socials i don't know um
you know you know what you lost your
comments all right play basketball with
me at perry harvey park don't do it if i
see anybody at perry harvey park i'm
gonna assume it's on site
i carry the strap on me you better be
unhomed the toaster is on my side at all
times
heater on deck
some of it's just relatable rap music
yeah i've heard all these terms before
um peace what else are guns called um
you know sometimes you'll be like that
steal that rambo they'll be like
smith and weston yeah
i know because they always say that
they're wesley
perfect thank god
beautiful goodbye great stuff
good
all right good seeing you folks
[Music]
you